good afternoon everyone
i'm here to provide an update on covid19
in alberta with dr hinshaw
the data we're sharing today is from
tuesday may the 31st to monday june the
6th and it was posted yesterday online
as usual if you've looked at the numbers
you know that there's a lot of good news
i'm pleased to report that all the data
including our pcr positivity rate and
wastewater surveillance shows a
continued trend of declining cova
transmission in the province
between may 31st and june 6th our
average pcr test positivity rate was
about 15 percent that's a decrease of 2
percent from the previous week
as well
waste water levels continue to trend
down
they're down to or near the level before
omicron in many communities
the levels are higher in edmonton and
calgary and the levels fluctuate from
day to day but they continue to trend
down
the result is that covid
admissions are down sharply in fact this
is the lowest number of total
hospitalizations we've seen since the
peak in the initial omicron wave and the
lowest number of icu admissions we've
seen since august
overall the wave of patients that
straining the system is beginning to
ease
in the smaller regional centers patient
numbers and total occupancy are at or
below the levels in the years before the
pandemic
the numbers are still high in edmonton
and calgary with a few sites over 100
percent occupancy but the levels are
beginning to ease there as well
there should be relief for the staff in
the coming weeks as the omicron ba2 wave
continues to recede and once again to
all of our frontline healthcare workers
i'd like to say thank you
now two weeks ago i said that available
data seemed to indicate that the ba2
wave was nearly behind us today we can
see that we are past this wave and in a
period of declining transmission
barring the arrival of any new variant
or sub variant that behaves differently
we expect to see low transmission rates
throughout the summer especially as more
activities move outside
i hope that every albertan has the
opportunity to get out and enjoy the
splendor of our province
this summer and the weeks ahead
as we said before we expect covid to
become more of a seasonal occurrence
with higher rates in the colder months
similar to the annual flu season
our teams at alberta health and ahs
all are are already looking ahead to the
fall and winter and making plans for a
potential rise in covet and influenza
cases then
and i can assure you we will be prepared
in the meantime we'll keep working to
add capacity to our health care system
it was subject to too much strain even
before covid and obviously the pandemic
has added to it
both by adding patients and by straining
the staff we need to care for them
let me give you just one point to show
you how big the disruption has been and
why we're seeing so much strain right
now
before kovid we normally saw right
around 2 million emergency visits a year
in this province
in 2021
that
dropped by a quarter and it stayed down
by about 10
through last year
that means 700 000 visits that would
normally happen just didn't happen
so now some of those patients are coming
in and they're sicker than they would
have been otherwise and that's on top of
the cases of covet itself right now
and a late season flu and other viruses
and all the other things that bring
waves of patients into our system
the care deficit is real it's a huge
challenge for the system and it's the
same right across our entire country
the strain is not because we're cutting
the budget or staff it's the opposite
we're adding them ahs has 800 more staff
working in emergency than before the
pandemic and 230 more paramedics but the
emergency departments and ems are still
under strain here and right across the
country
it's been a tough few months on top of a
tough very tough two years but the
system is catching up and will do more
as a current wave recedes
the surgery weightless is around 72 000
most recently compared to 68 000 before
the pandemic
cancer screening is one of those
services that saw volumes drop early in
the pandemic but the staff and
clinicians have worked hard to get
patients back in and screening levels
last year were almost back to normal
levels
and we'll keep adding capacity right
across the system we'll get ems response
times back within ahs's targets where
they were until last summer when volume
started to surge and we'll get the
surgery wait lists down not just to
where they were
before covet but lower
we'll do that by continuing to resource
the system to add capacity and by hiring
and training more health care workers
there's a lot more to do and i know
things are still very tough especially
for the people working in the big
hospitals in downtown calgary and in
edmonton
but we're getting past the current wave
of covet and we're putting the resources
into the system to support recovery and
to build an even stronger health system
than we had before covet so thank you
and i'll now ask dr hinshaw to provide
her
update thank you minister and good
afternoon everyone
i would like to remind albertans that it
continues to be important to stay home
if we are feeling even a little bit
unwell
and we encourage employers to help
facilitate employees staying home if
sick to reduce the transmission of any
virus wherever possible
this is why i'm joining today's update
remotely
well the focus of these updates is
covid19
i would like to begin today with an
update on an emerging public health
matter monkey pox
i can confirm that in total as of today
four cases have been identified in
alberta
these adult individuals are
self-isolating and i want to express my
appreciation for their assistance with
contact tracing and investigation
at this time the overall risk of
contracting monkey pox remains low in
alberta
however it is important to be aware that
most but not all
cases in the recent global outbreak have
been seen in men who reported sex with
multiple male partners
this means that there may be an elevated
risk in that community right now
we've reached out to organizations
across the province serving this
community and after receiving feedback
have provided them information to best
support them in outreach to their
members
i want to be clear that this specific
outreach does not mean this virus can
only impact one community
we are working with these organizations
and sharing this current risk factor
information
to ensure that people have accurate
timely data about the outbreak
this is not being done to shame or
stigmatize anyone and it does not mean
that anyone who has contracted monkey
pox or is a close contact has done
anything wrong
monkey pox is mainly spread by close
skin-to-skin contact by some with
somebody with symptoms or by touching
things contaminated with the virus such
as sharing clothes or bedding
it is critical that anyone experiencing
symptoms such as fever swollen glands
new sores or a rash self isolate and
call healthlink at 811.
these are common symptoms and most
people with these symptoms will have
another cause
however being aware of these symptoms is
particularly important for anyone who
has recently had a new sexual partner or
anyone who believes they have been in
prolonged close contact with someone
with monkey pox
i want to underscore the importance of
not shaming or stigmatizing any one
group and at the same time providing
accurate information so people can make
informed choices about their health
importance of not shaming or
stigmatizing any one group and at the
same time providing accurate information
so people can make informed choices
about their health
turning to today's covet update
between tuesday may 31st and monday june
6 our pcr test positivity ranged from
13.1 to 17.1 with an average of 15.1
percent for the week
as minister copping mentioned earlier
the number of people with covet 19 in
hospital has decreased
currently there are 816 people with
covid including 24 in the icu
this is a decrease of about 20 percent
over the past two weeks
sadly between may 17th and may 23rd
42 deaths related to covet 19 were
reported to alberta health
i would also like to report that
following a recent review as per our
usual process
33 previously reported covert deaths
between october 2021 and april 2022 have
been reclassified as non-coveted and
removed from our total
as a result this week the total number
of reported deaths from kovit have
increased by nine to four thousand five
hundred ninety seven
we must never forget that this number
represents thousands of albertans who
were loved by their family and friends
and are greatly missed
my sympathies are with the loved ones of
these albertans and with anyone grieving
the loss of someone they cared about no
matter the cause
as the minister said we are continuing
to see a decrease in the number of our
indicators
and we know that we have the benefit of
the summer season on our side to further
drive down transmission
however that being said is important
that we remember that learning to live
with kovid does not mean forgetting
about it
covid19 is still present in our
communities and can pose a risk to us
our loved ones and our healthcare system
if we let it
we only need to look at our data to see
that there are still cases across the
province and while fewer by the day
there are still many albertans who are
seriously ill
i want to remind albertans who have not
yet been vaccinated or who have not
received all doses they are eligible for
that vaccines without a doubt continue
to be our best protection
currently less than 50 percent of
albertans have received the third dose
that they are eligible for
it's if it has been five months since
your second dose
and you're 12 years of age or older
i encourage you to get your third dose
today
as we think about our plans for the
coming months we need to continue to
reflect on the information available to
us and make decisions based on our own
personal context
this means considering wearing a mask at
times when transmission is higher or
when gathering with loved ones who are
at higher risk of severe outcomes
in addition it will always remain vital
that all of us remember to continue good
habits that will serve us well as we
continue to live with covet and other
infections such as washing our hands
regularly and avoiding being around
others if we're sick
by continuing to take simple actions
every day we can continue to protect one
another
thank you and we're happy to take
questions
thanks dr hinshaw no one in person here
in edmonton or i think in calgary so
we'll go straight to the phones i think
we have three reporters online so
operator will take the first one please
adam toy global
uh yeah question for the health minister
just wanted to clarify a comment that uh
you said earlier that um we're at a lo
the lowest number of total
hospitalizations pre omicron did i hear
that correctly and and i'm just
wondering
if that's
actually the case because the the data
would seem to indicate otherwise
yeah so so the the the numbers we are
right now is at uh
816 in terms of total hospitalization so
that is you know significantly lower
than we've seen in regards to uh uh
earlier periods dealing with omar
thanks adam you have a follow-up
a question uh open question for uh
either the health minister of the chief
medical officer of health uh
i'm just wondering about uh confidence
in um surveilling uh emerging variants
uh as they come along um i notice on the
on the um the data dashboard that there
is now a handful of cases over the last
number of weeks that have uh been tested
positive for the ba ba-4 and the ba-5
as as more uh
variants and inevitably come about are
you confident that
restricting pcr testing and variant
testing to only those who are in high
risk settings or are at high risk for
complications is going to be enough to
be able to catch
potentially more
serious
variants in the future
do we have enough surveillance
maybe i can take that question um so
what's important to remember is that
public health surveillance is something
that
has been done for many many years and
there is a science to public health
surveillance about how to set up
representative systems to be able to
understand what is circulating in the
community
and when we expanded our pcr testing
eligibility very broadly early in the
pandemic i want to be clear that the
main purpose of expanding that
eligibility was not actually for
surveillance there was a side benefit of
being able to have
access to to large amounts of data but
at that time our main goal of expanding
that eligibility was to detect as many
cases as possible and to put in measures
around cases and contacts to contain the
spread as the virus has evolved and as
the incubation period has grown shorter
the virus has become more infectious it
is simply not possible to contain the
virus with the use of broad pcr testing
and so what we're doing right now with
respect to using wastewater surveillance
as well as using geographically
representative community surveillance of
pcr swabs
as well as the pcr tests that come in
through emergency departments and
hospitals
is a good representation of what is
circulating in the community and would
help us understand what the the strains
are that are driving transmission so
yes i believe that our current approach
is sufficient to be able to help us
understand what is circulating and to
respond to new strains as they emerge
and if if i can add you know this is
this approach is similar that's being
taken in all other jurisdictions across
canada right now
okay thanks minister and dr henshaw
we'll go to the next caller please
matt woodman ctv
hey there uh my questions for dr hinshaw
we've heard from at least one
organization that received one of these
monkey pox fact sheets in an email they
they feel it is they are being
stigmatized similar to the hiv aids
crisis so what do you say to these
organizations to reassure them it's not
about shaming it's about public health
i would say first of all that i'm very
sorry that
that that caused um that that particular
fact sheet caused that that was
certainly not the intent we did try to
get feedback from several organizations
about the wording in the language um and
did our best to
balance the need for timely
dissemination of accurate information
with the consultation with several
representative groups but i absolutely
understand that groups who didn't have
that opportunity to provide feedback in
the content
may feel that
they would have wished that we had
framed things differently we are
continuing to engage with organizations
and welcome their feedback and if there
are ways that we can speak about this
that provide accurate information about
current risk factors so people can
take control over their own health
without stigmatizing we absolutely
welcome that feedback and will continue
to work to do our best to not stigmatize
and at the same time provide
current accurate information
thanks dr hanshaw matt do you have a
follow-up
i do yeah i'm curious to know why we
haven't been releasing the areas in the
province where these cases live similar
to when covid cases were first emerging
in alberta we would provide you know say
the city of calgary or the city of
edmonton but we haven't seen that from
the province yet why not
uh
early on when we have very small numbers
of cases we do
sometimes
um choose to not speak about the
locations to
minimize the chance of any kind of
confidentiality breach
so that's something that we continually
evaluate about the importance of
transparency against the importance of
making sure that people's individual
health information is kept
private and so we will continue to
assess and if
we reach that point where it's important
to be able to provide that geographical
information that we will do so at this
point what's important to know
is that individuals
who
are
experiencing any of the symptoms of
monkey pox and again the most likely
explanation would be something else but
that they should seek medical attention
and be evaluated in case they have been
in contact and again in close contact
with somebody who had the infection
thanks dr hanchow operator we'll go to
the next caller please
josh aldridge calgary harold
good afternoon uh my first question uh
is for dr hinshaw
uh
just kind of follow up on that it's
almost more clarification that i'm
looking for when it comes to uh to
monkey pox you said in other
jurisdictions it's showing up in a very
specific demographic the four cases in
alberta are are they part of that
demographic as well
or
and is there a concern or
potential for us to start seeing monkey
pucks in other jurors or in other
demographics uh in the population or are
those cases more rare than the uh
demographics that we are currently
seeing
what we know about the global outbreak
is that
individuals who have
had very close contact with multiple
other individuals and in this particular
outbreak many of the cases have been
individuals who report having multiple
sexual partners uh it's this is not a
sexually transmitted infection but it is
one that can be
spread through close physical contact uh
and so in this particular case again
that's why we are sharing that
information with um groups in alberta
who
and again this is not
limited to individuals who are men
reporting sex with other men this could
be anyone who's having
close physical contact with multiple
other people
and so
the infection because it does spread
through that close direct contact
is something that could spread to other
people other groups
and what we want to do is provide
information to anyone
who might be at risk of being in close
contact with somebody who has the virus
so people can make decisions about their
own health at this particular time and
and of course if the information changes
in terms of where we are seeing cases we
would share that information
and this virus is absolutely not limited
to any one particular group
thanks dr insha is there a follow-up
uh yes
and this is um again with uh dr hinshaw
but uh going back to covet uh you talk
about the need to get vaccinated and to
get your doses is could we see the
potential for the
parameters of a pork dose open up
further than what they are
for those who are wanting to get that
fourth dose to protect themselves even
more
than what they currently are able to
against further waves or further strains
of globe 19.
we are working with the national
advisory committee in our alberta
advisory committee to understand
their assessment of the current evidence
on who benefits most from that
additional dose of vaccine
the last conversation we had with our
provincial advisory committee and the
data that we looked at in alberta
indicated that
people who were under the age of 70
we're not seeing increased risk of
severe outcomes if they had that third
dose or that first booster and we do
continue to watch the data and listen to
what the national advisory committee
recommends if the national advisory
committee and provincial advisory
committee
change their recommendations we will as
we have always done listen carefully to
what they recommend
but to date again their advice has been
to focus the second booster on those who
are at the highest risk of severe
outcomes for whom that third dose does
not appear to be providing sufficient
protection at this time
thanks dr ian shaw uh we'll take one
last caller uh so operator can you put
through our last call please
lisa johnson edmonton journal
hi thanks for taking my question this is
for the minister i'm i'm wondering if
you can respond to some ahs numbers that
the ndp released today um they say that
for the first time ambulances from st
alberts bruce grove
for saskatchewan and stress kona county
responded to more calls in edmonton than
in their own
communities in in 2021 based off those
numbers i'm wondering if you have
specific concerns about this imbalance
between ambulances being dispatched more
often away from their their home
communities rather than the other way
around from edmonton to the outlying
communities
yeah so thanks for the question i do
recognize that this is an issue and my
my understanding in terms of the data
that was being presented was
last year 2122
versus the year private
previously which is 2021
uh and that that is the case that you
know as especially as we have the
numbers increase last august
a 30 increase in call volumes
you are seeing um to be able to respond
to those those call volumes and the and
the longer wait times that we had in our
emergency departments
pulling in ambulances from outside of
the major centers so we've you know
that's part of the reason why as part of
budget 2022 we invested 64 million
dollars uh into our ems system uh that
included ten new ambulances in uh in
edmonton and they're coming online a
number are going to be coming online at
the uh
the end of this month and and and then a
number number more uh by september so
you know you know this total of uh
20 in in
calgary and edmonton that we committed
to in the budget we'll have 19 up and
running by uh september so that will
help uh alleviate that as well as that
there's there has been changes recently
and this is you know part of the
10-point plan that ahs put out that was
announced in february uh to be able to
try to change our the the rules in
regards to uh calling ambulances so that
if an ambulance from outside the city is
called into
edmonton for example um that unless it's
a urgent call they would be dispatched
back to their home territory as opposed
to staying in edmonton to be able to
reduce the amount of times that's coming
in and as well
i appointed an advisory committee they
made some recommendations um 10
recommendations the uh the ministerial
advisory committee to address this exact
issue so for example um community
response unit pilot in strathcona uh
county uh the maintaining you know units
in strathcona county that will not go
into edmonton similarly in spruce grove
a pilot that we're running there that
that would enable uh
so the the firefighter paramedics to
attend calls uh and bring them to the to
the hospital but but primarily provide
more resources so all of that combined
you will actually see those uh those
numbers drops and and i haven't got the
data in front of me right now but if we
probably looked over the last few months
that probably dropped already i know
we did an assessment in uh in calgary a
number of weeks ago
the numbers of ambulances being called
from around the calgary area
into calgary had declined significantly
and we're keeping them more in the home
so we do recognize uh that was an issue
i'm not surprised that the data when you
compare last year the government year
ending in uh
in april of 22 to the year previously
that there was an uh an increase of uh
ambulances being called in to the
centers we recognize that and we're
addressing it
thanks minister uh lisa a follow-up
yeah thanks i the last time we had an
update on this i know the ahs was
working to fill 40 primary care
paramedic positions can i wonder if you
can give an update on that and if the
ems
advisory committee has
started to consider
any of the recommendations from the hsaa
i know that they had recommended very
specifically or called for very
specifically
um for
casual temporary contracts to be bumped
up to full-time um and you're familiar
with those calls and and uh
essentially trying to deal with uh
problems with getting paramax paramedics
off their shifts on time to deal with
burnout um have those been discussed by
the committee
so i i don't know i at this point in
time uh the committee is uh is going to
be uh providing with me a uh
a interim report uh i haven't had a
chance to take a look at that yet but
that's i expect that any uh any day now
um
and look at that and that so i'm not
sure whether that's gonna be part of the
interim report or a part of the final
report we did have a separate
subcommittee set up to look look exactly
at just that issue in terms of you know
ability to retain uh paramedics but one
of the issues that was identified by one
of these subcommittees
is that you know paramedics it's it's a
a challenging job
that there is a burnout
um that people already you know the the
length of a career as a paramedic has
actually declined over time uh and so
how do we keep people there so they're
looking at that i know one of the items
that they're looking at is it was also
part of the ahs ten point plan uh was
dealing with uh worker fatigue uh in a
different model uh in terms of managing
that particularly in rural areas so i'm
looking forward to reviewing the interim
report uh and then we'll be able to take
a look and see whether that's part of
that but there's like their work is
ongoing um the final report is due in
july
thanks minister uh and thanks dr hinshaw
we'll wrap it up there i will see you
again for an update in a couple of weeks
uh and just one note i i heard at one
point early in the q a that the live
feed might have been cut
reporters i presume you heard the answer
because i was hearing it in here but
obviously
reporters particularly if we missed or
you missed any part of an answer please
follow up separately and we'll fill in
any gap so thanks very much again and
that's it for now
thank you